واعمل قلب الحدث من سان فرانسيسكو وينضم
الينا زميلي حسين الطود ومراس العربيه
مرحبا بك حسين دعنا في الصوره يبدو ان
الاعداد ستذا تتزايد هناك تسريح لعدد اخر
من الموظفين هناك مخاوف كبيره تجتاح
العالم الحكومات السفارات المستخدمين كيف
سيكون الوضع بالنسبه لتويتر خلال الساعات
القليله المقبله
صباح الخير رشا بالفعل اليوم وفي الحقيقه
كما يقول المراقبون الان هو يوم اختبار
يوم سيبدا كاس العالم من المرجح بحسب
الكثيرين من خبراء التقنيه تقريبا 50% همم
يفشل تدري ان يحدث هنا كان قطاعات بسبب
نقص الحاصل الان ب- الموظفين التقنيين
والمهندسين عن صيانه الموقع
والتاكد من استمراريته جنسيابيه بالنسبه
للتسريحات التسريحات الموظفين هناك من
يشير الى تضارب الان داخل المؤسسه مؤسس
تويتر التي تظهر خلفي همم هنا في سان
فرانسيسكو بان لهم ماسك يطلب من الموظفين
همم
الاستقاله البقاء والعمل ساعات طويله
وبتفاني ثم يرسل همم بريد الكترونيا يطلب
من البعض البقاء والاجتماع معه كما حصل
يوم الجمعه عندما طلب من يجيد البرمجه بان
يستمع معه هنا والان لا نسمع من خلال بانه
سيتم تصريح عدد اخر من الموظفين هنا كمان
يشير الى تضارب في قرارات مصر في الايام
الاخيره همم سبب همم الوضعيه التي يمر بها
تويتر الان وبسبب المشاكل التي التقنيه
التي قد يواجهها همم بالنسبه ايضا فقط
اذكر بالنسبه لدونالد ترامب دونالد ترامب
هنا كمان يقول انه فجاه الجميع لك في
الحقيقه هو كان له موقف صادق بانه لن يعود
الى المتر عندما همم اشترى له الناس همم
المنصه همم في شهر اكتوبر الماضي
ولكن حسين هل استطعت الوصول لبعض الموظفين
والعاملين داخل تويتر لنقل الصوره من داخل
الشركه ما الذي يحدث
البارحه رشا كنا رصدنا ودخول بعض الاشخاص
الى موقع الشركه الى مدخل الشركه تحولنا
اللحاق بهم ولكن الامن همم المسؤول عنها
طلب منها الابتعاد والبقاء الخارج سيصير
مع المصور فقط لاوريكم هذا هو تويتر الان
ااه هذا هو المبنى هذه الاشاره
الشهيره له همم في على يمين همم الشاشه
يكون المدخل الرئيسي هناك همم البارحه
عندما حاولنا همم
في ساعات الصباح الاولى استطعنا ان ندخل
حتى المدخل الرئيسي همم في الداخل ولكن في
همم في ساعات الظهر عندما شهدنا بعض
الاشخاص يدخلوا لا نعرف الحقيقه ان كانوا
همم موظفين ام لا ولكن حاولنا اللحاق بهم
لنسالهم عن ما يجري يتكلم موظفين مع ما
يواجهونه لكن تدخل هنا همم جهاز الامني
همم شركه تويتر وطلب منك قالوا لنا هذه
هذه ملكيه خاصه الرجاء البقاء في الخارج
وعدم الدخول الى همم حرم المكان هذان
المبنيان رشا هما تبعا لتر يعني لديها
القسم الاكبر تلك هي العلامه هذا المبنى
الاخر وهذا المبنى هنا ايضا همم مؤسسه
لكاميرا العربيه ومراس العربيه الزمير
حسين الطود من سان فرانسيسكو مقرات شركه
تويتر الزميل حسين يرصد لنا بالصوره
الواقع في محيط هذه الشركات حسين تتحدث عن
دخول الموظفين او اعداد منهم الى الداخل
لكن الامن لا يسمح لوسائل الاعلام بالتحدث
معهم ولكن هذه صور خاصه وحصريه لنا من
مقررات شركه تويتر في سان فرانسيسكو تفضل
حسين
نعم صار احاول ان نقترب الان لنرى ان كان
كنا سا نستطيع الدخول ام انهم سيطلبوا منا
المغادره مره اخرى
كما حصل البارح
هذا هو احد المداخل الرئيسيه هنا هذان
المبنيان رشا
ساقترب اكثر همم من المبنى من المدخل
الرئيسي
كما ترين طبعا هنا هنا يوجد عدد من
المحلات الاخرى همم المتاجر الاخرى ولكن
تويتر موجود في الطوابق العليا
نعم
المدخل الرئيسي
عند الباب
هذا هو المكتب اذا رايت العلامه من هنا
يصعدون الى الطوابق العليا للشركه حيث
اجتمع ماس منذ يومين مع عدد من الموظفين
حيث
ممكن كانوا في الداخل يتحدثون الى احد
رجال الامن المسؤول عن الشركه ثم تدخل رجل
الاعلى هذا فقط هو المدخل العمل في
الطوابق الاعلى هذا فقط والمدخل هذا هذا
نعم هذا هذا في هذا المبنى هناك كما قلت
هناك مبنيان العمل يتم في الطوابق العليا
حسب ما شرح لنا هنا همم
المسؤولون في عن عن همم
عن المباني
تتحدثنا الى بعضهم من البارحه قالوا انه
متى شركه تويتر موجوده في الطوابق العليا
يتم الدخول اليها من هذا الباب ومن باب
اخر ولكن هذا هو الباب الرئيسي للشركه
وكما ترعين العلامه موجوده هناك من يريد
ان يدخل الى الشركه عليها ان يدخل من هذا
الباب ثم يصعد في المصعد الى الطوابق
العليا وهي هناك اكثر من طابق لشركه
تويوتا حسب ما فهمنا من بعض العاملين هنا
في هذه
العمارات هذه الابنيه هذه
طبعا يجب ان نذكر اليوم الاحد الساعه 8:00
الان على الساعه السادسه والاربعين دقيقه
صباحا نتوقع غدا ان يكون هناك قدوم اكيد
للموظفين سنرصدها بطبيعه الحال مدرسه صباح
الاولى
لشاشه العربيه زميلي حسين الطوب من سان
فرانسيسكو شكرا لك وكنت هذه صور خاصه
لمقرات تويتر في مدينه سان فرانسيسكو صور
خاصه لكاميرا العربي العربيه